Jordan you were also part of the Japan
trip how many times have you been to
Japan before that just once oh just once
okay but I was always infatuated with
Japanese culture but I was I'll say now
I was very surprised at having been
invited to Japan uh because I didn't
have like
um a hardcore well-known connection to
Japan so uh I'm still surprised that I
was asked and I frankly don't know
unless you had the Macchio thing already
in your back pocket I don't know why I
went to Georgia was it just the two
segments it was just toilet three no and
there was uh there was the the two
things the kaiseki meal the toilet and
then the two fans who you surprised oh
right right the married couple yeah we I
talked to about Japan because I was
curious about your experience with it
and you mentioned the Karate Kid too
yeah and then it was you loved it you
loved Japan because it was filming
Okinawa and everything and then I
Googled the movie and that's where I
learned it that's why the trip happened
just to catch you in one I was like oh
my God it was shot in Hawaii and then we
we went about but you know Ralph Macho
did not send it was like the day before
maybe the day of we were gonna bust you
on it and then I think Conan's idea to
get Ralph Macchio to make the video and
it's like yes oh that's of course
perfect so much better and he that video
came in like
three hours before the dinner your
entire fascination
with Japan
stems from the fact that you saw
Karate Kid too yeah
and then it was filmed in where Okinawa
Okinawa
I have a message here for you
please press play
and hold that out to the camera as you
watch it
hi Conan it's me Ralph Macchio listen
I'm sorry to interrupt I just wanted to
tell that Jordan guy that all the scenes
in Karate Kid Part Two That was supposed
to be Japan were actually shot in Hawaii
those real dinosaurs in Jurassic Park
[Applause]
laughs
tone in the whole time understanding now
that he knew he had that in his back
pocket I saw no hints that anything like
that was coming he right and he was
patient enough but that was a long
dinner it was like an hour and a half
you were so aggressive with him in that
dinner you were I've never seen you go
after him and he was taking it because
he knew he was right he had this well he
was also getting we edited that that was
a long edit because he was getting you
too and and there had to be a bat we
tried to keep it so it was a balance so
you weren't like oh Jordan's being too
mean and or Conan's being so it was kind
of
keeping it balanced up to that moment a
little bit I'm curious now that we're
here why do you remember like you were
aggressively was it just your thought
like oh this is
it wasn't honestly it wasn't it was not
a deliberate Choice okay and it never I
was curious I guess my reactions happen
organically yeah okay and that that's
one of the benefits you guys uh don't
like to tell me in advance you tell me
like tell me as little as possible you
know right clearly for a trip like this
you have to let me know to pack a bag
but otherwise if you have the option to
just send a camera crew into my office
you'll take it right and um it may
please you to know that I don't uh
pre-plan how I'll behave good well you
know what it goes back to when we're in
Dallas yeah and we've mentioned that and
we went Cowboys because I mentioned that
shot that's in Stetson was from New
Jersey and you went off on a 10-minute
thing on travels extensively across
Texas I assumed you knew we're doing it
and you you prepare this oh uh you went
you asked me multiple times
laughs
it's been thorough
ly you know they've been multiple times
where I've been questioned by various
writers okay yes about some of the
things I say yes
um just about I remember writers came to
my house one day they said
who writes your tweets
and then that was another situation
where you came to me and said oh you
know did you research that or whatever
it was and uh no no but I just assumed I
was like oh we shouldn't tell Jordan
where we're going because he's going
well yeah I think even at pre I think
there was such success with the I guess
the coming in late one was the first
ambush if you'll use that term of many
[Music]
what's going on here
that's your reaction
you just walk into your office feels
like an acceptable reaction to me and I
guess the results were good enough that
and in that case the Ambush was
justified the premise of the whole bit
but I think that it worked and then um
the thought was well this worked let's
not mess with it but like the old ones
on on uh late night that Frank uh came
up with right they were the Italian
dinner there was one during the writer
strike where uh I was fully aware of
those and those uh did well too it's
true that couldn't mean in advance
doesn't necessarily hurt it unless the
premise is such that it depends on my
ignorance well I'm sure you started to
smell out when I mean it wasn't just
that you came in every day afraid that
uh remote
I absolutely would you come in camera
like every day there's no camera ready
for me but uh at any moment see the
problem there's no camera already
because he's always right
I apologize when you've been ambushed a
few times yeah even if you don't don't
get ambushed again you don't know that
you're not going to get ambushed right
so every time I was called down to this
day every time I was called down to
Conan's office for a legitimate reason
part of me expected to see a camera crew
in there and like are you a lot you see
me come by and just speak well that you
were a big tip-off but like a lot of the
things too was one of the excuses to get
me in the office at a certain day in a
certain time for for one of these
instances was that there was a fictional
meeting so I got an invite to a meeting
about something that had basis and maybe
what I was working on the time and then
it turned out to not be a meaning so
then again going forward when I would
get meeting requests that didn't sound
completely Justified I was almost
certain that this was just an excuse to
get me but then there was plenty of
unjustified meetings that just happened
I guess yeah I guess so it goes and but
to this day because now we're not in the
office on on a regular skit this being
the office we're not here on a regular
schedule so when I get called in for
something uh it occurs to me that there
could be some um yeah yeah so that a
hard way to live your life it is I mean
you know again I I don't I didn't
necessarily change anything about the
way I would behave when I was on camera
so it wasn't a big deal in that respect
but you know sometimes you want to just
sit and relax and know that you're not
going to be exposed in that way the
machio thing was the first time I
actually saw like I felt bad for like
his dreams but I didn't feel but I know
that was the whole thing it looked it
looked like you looked devastating yeah
you looked devastated
[Laughter]
[Applause]
inconsequential the fact that that and I
made an error in the shooting location
of a movie was inconsequential to me at
least from my own perspective it did not
diminish my appreciation for the week it
did not even diminish my desire to go to
Japan because of what I saw in the movie
because I understand that movies are
fake and they were presenting something
that may as well have been in Japan
because it looked that way and kind of
represented the culture that was I know
you guys it worked comedically to have
me devastated in that moment but the
reality is because the venomous that
he's talking about like after you found
out after that happened you were on the
attack even more than I've ever seen I I
guess I was reacting to like the the way
the energy was going in in the
conversation but uh again it wasn't
deliberate and I wasn't actually upset
okay well you're already traumatized
from us it was going to meetings every
day I see comedically why it worked but
part part of my reaction was like I
can't believe he went to all this
trouble to get Ralph Macchio to record
this message
um and you know presented and after I
hour and a half of sitting here like it
takes it takes restraint to have that
there for an hour and a half and not
like show it sooner especially given the
conversation yeah it was masterful he
was playing the longer the long game